nous allons maintenant lancer une
opération gens sont vraiment très
française parce que tout échange nous
avons entendu le son des chansons
françaises et les chansons d adaptation
mais qui était un petit peu influencé
par le rythme on est un petit peu twist
est tel qu'un bon rythme français qui a
fait ses preuves
encore une polka non une marche alors
une chanson qui séparait la plus jolie
julie qui serait une marche
voyez ça avec un interprète populaire
oui vous voulez essayer de trouver la
plus jolie julie de france voilà
pourquoi pas le plus beau jude non
écoutés l'année prochaine seulement bon
alors vous avez mon interprète pourquoi
oui vous faudrait un interprète
oh oui je vois populaire et va buter
emporte la chanson et le concours des
villes de froid zappy max de l'homme qui
me vaut cette charmante
[Musique]
à
tu es la plus jolie julie seule la plus
jolie julie la plus jolie julie tu es
celle que j'aime tant gili que j'aime
tant chili éperdument gili pourtant
vinoy vie
et en push au lit et pour tes yeux
blagon je ferai des folies du et celle
que j'ai
quand tu lis beaucoup passionnément à la
folie
la première fois julich je t'ai vu je
n'ai rien dit la deuxième fois je suis
vie que je t'ai vu j'ai tout compris
mais la troisième fois julie jeter
conduite à la mairie la quatrième julie
c'est cette nuit
[Musique]
te
m
[Musique]
oh
ah la la
[Musique]
à
tu es la plus jolie julie joly la rue
jolie julie la plus jolie judith
tu es celle que j'aime tant julie que ça
n'a pas de prix que ça n'a pas de prix
j'adore fraude
à l'affiché on peut sauter
ça puisque c'est
si tu es celle que j'aime
quand julie passionnément vraiment julie
à la folie
[Musique]